cette horde actions du matin jusqu'au
milieu de l'après-midi pour la défense
des services publics elle la cgt ne
lâche rien plusieurs semaines après le
début du mouvement des cheminots est
alors que la convergence des luttes
reste un échec pour le moment le
syndicat continue d'occuper le terrain
social à saint quentin en yvelines
que ce soit la sncf que ça soit à tous
toute la santé dernière en date les
allocations et hier donc pour nous c'est
lançant des services publics au sens
large pas que ce statut mais les cafés
ces femmes qui sont en train de fermer
il ya 400 points dans le département qui
sont en train de fermer la politique du
gouvernement en ligne de mire pour faire
passer les messages il faut bien sûr
mobiliser pas forcément simple à l'heure
d'aller au travail
les gens sont quand même sympa ils nous
disent bonjour ils prennent le papier
donc nous déjà on est content s'ils le
prennent ce qu'ils vont prendre le temps
de le lire
après on sent parfois quand même une
certaine résignation rassemblement
devant la gare auprès d'axa routier
majeur mais aussi auprès des salariés de
la fonction publique
la centrale est en campagne et l'enjeu
est de taille le syndicat joue sa
première place lors des élections
professionnelles en décembre prochain
dont la confiance dans le fait qu'on va
rester au premier
le premier sujet nous qui nous occupe
c'est le niveau de la participation
parce qu'on voit qu aux élections
politiques
il ya des problèmes de participation
électorale ça peut être le cas aussi aux
élections professionnelles donc le
message qu'on veut faire passer c'est
que si on veut continuer de servir la
démocratie au travail il faut vraiment
que nos collègues vote en 2017 la cgt
avait perdu sa première place dans le
privé au profit de la cfdt
le taux de participation était alors
inférieur à 43 %